Dwight Howard's best career move ever
was overcoming a food addiction he had
early in his career and it wasn't just
any addiction he had a think for candy
bars and he was eating them at a
ridiculous rate Dwight was eating at
least 24 candy bars a day for years he
had a stash everywhere from his kitchen
to his room to even in his car and it
gets worse he even had a routine of
eating McDonald's before every game but
everything changed once he was traded to
the Lakers one of the team's
nutritionists found a nerve dysfunction
in Dwight from all the candy he ate once
he heard that going on a major fast was
a no-brainer and his discipline was very
impressive he went from eating candy
every day to only eating two green
apples and working out three times a day
so it's safe to say Dwight made the
right choice by taking extra care of his
body instead of consuming two dozen
candy bars a day